a lot of people say that gender is  complex and sex is simple as a biology  teacher i highly disagree  can you see the crazy eyes i can see it  gender is really easy gender is how  someone identifies so just listen to  them when they tell you if they're male  female or non-binary do you remember the  good old days when it was just man woman  this man well okay okay who am i sex is  more complex biology teachers like to  boil it down to xx and x y but there are  so many more combinations than that of  the sex chromosomes i'm gonna be honest  i have no idea what she just said but i  don't think i need a science degree to  know the difference between male and  female  thank you